aussi de ce journal est à présent
consacré aux multiples facettes de
l'informatique dans notre vie
quotidienne nous parlerons dans un
instant des appareils intelligents qui
obéissent à notre voie mais nous
commençons par un aspect plus polémique
car l'informatique a tendance parfois à
nous dépasser comment peut-on par
exemple le faire confiance aux fameuses
internet pour acheter la distance les
français sont plutôt méfiants éléments
de réponse avec patricia charnolé et
jean lui melun il y a quatre ans les 3
suisses ont créé un site sur internet
bilan 50 commandes par jour contre 80
milles avec la vente par correspondance
ces chiffres montrent que les français
hésitent encore à se lancer dans le
cyber commerce d'où la nécessité de
rassurer
première étape le consommateur donne son
numéro de carte de crédit deuxième étape
le vendeur doit de protéger
alors ce numéro est immédiatement
cryptée par le logiciel spécialisé
intégré au site
ça circule dans le réseau ça arrive chez
nous est là nous procédons au décryptage
du numéro et ensuite nous nous
procéderons à l'opération bancaire
traditionnel tout comme quand les
clientes comment par unitel ou par
téléphone au système n'a jamais été
violée on n'a jamais eu de problème
vraiment aucun problème de piratage ou
de violations système depuis quatre ans
un système à vionnaz bhl pas vraiment
aux états unis des pirates informatiques
ont réussi à identifier des numéros de
cartes sur plusieurs sites
le cryptage constitue en tout cas une
sécurité minimum
ainsi hélène pionnière de l'achat
electronics assure que le site où elle
veut acheter et bien protégé où il
m'arrive quand un site n'est pas
sécurisé et le logiciel vous informe si
le site est sécurisé pour les
transactions financières ou pas quand le
site n'est pas ce que je ne donne pas
mes coordonnées la sécurité totale des
paiements est elle envisageable
non mais pour les spécialistes l'achat
sur internet n'est pas plus dangereux
que l'utilisation traditionnelle de sa
carte bancaire
la vraie difficulté de mettre au point
des normes internationales
c'est arrivé à les accords
à échelle régionale puis mondiale pour
mettre en oeuvre des systèmes de
sécurisation qui soient les mêmes dans
l'ensemble banque actuellement moins de
10 % des français se disent prêts à
payer en ligne
pourtant les prévisions pour l'an 2000
sont vertigineuses
les ventes aux particuliers en france
sur internet représenterait alors 18
milliards de francs